[Music]
all right so I know that there was talk
of people wanting to go back to Vegas
sometime soon three rooms particularly
boys we had a group chat about it and it
was tempting that I wasn't included so
we should have included you also the
demon Tim have just taken huge hits of
hot sauce and they're crying like little
babies so don't mind that's why it's all
good I was tearing up like a baby I
didn't make noise that's true Nadeem
threw up many times like a baby deep to
look like a [ __ ] handled his [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh stupid little baby man little
baby sexy little baby sexy we never saw
what sexy of me honestly I'll put this
double or nothing hot like this cute
little hands okay so Vegas yes
Vegas is now open after the quarantine
but I personally don't feel inclined to
go there right the cleanest Vegas will
ever be that's a good point
that's a good point so blaze the rooms
are so [ __ ] cheap my homey was gonna
go two weeks you all right last time you
went for his birthday last year he had a
room that was the penthouse it was I
think like 2009 right he got for three
nights when he looked again it was a
humming 150 at night really we're going
so do you remember what Jumba and Ryan
had their birthday yes I was there at
the sky loft an engineer who now yeah
it's 10 G's a night back then it was
this was at the UM and James fellow no
no no no no no no no no the other on the
palms that's where they had it okay well
they should have had it the MGM [ __ ]
that's 10 G's tonight it's 700 bucks a
night really oh [ __ ] even been inside
the [ __ ] vacuum that's how
that's how crazy different up yep you're
down now I'm down now all the
restaurants open so just one of our
workers he he's from there so when he
went they opened the restaurants but
it's in LA if you're a restaurant the
tables are so spread out it's not back
to normal it's like open but it's still
like only the dealers are wearing masks
they're in the videos that I've seen the
people walking around are not wearing
masks and desolate and gamble grabs
I don't really club and the clubs aren't
open so it's fine I'm not convinced yet
but yes okay you don't miss secondhand
smoke well I don't see the first wave of
people get hit first and see what
happens it's the cleanest no one's gonna
get hit the second wave of people get
hit man it's vacuum what more do you
need
they'd open for a minute biggest time
yeah okay and if you go and when you go
be sure to take note of the pool
situation because recently a highly
experienced biological and chemical
warfare expert came out about some
stuffy and some research he did on the
Las Vegas pools why'd you change stuff
you know research well because I wanted
to clarify I was research okay like some
stuff he did sounds like very vague
research so so he was on a mission back
in 98 or 99 he can't really remember but
it was one of those years and there was
I know there was that moves December so
it was like on a cusp
so there was a case he was working on
and they wanted to have him analyze
three samples of clear liquid to see if
one of them was tainted with some
biological or chemical warfare going go
on deity okay Tanja's and tape and also
I feel like you're heading towards like
the water was from a pool in Vegas and
they found all types of jizz in it well
kind of that's what made me laugh okay
so the sample that they were originally
trying to
as the the very or the other variables
but the like almost like the placebo
ones that they were like so they didn't
want the scientists to know which ones
which one was the tainted one to taint
their research the one sample was tap
water and the other sample was Las Vegas
pool water one and what they found was
the the actual specimen didn't have the
chemical warfare in it but they were
very concerned about the Las Vegas pool
water it happened to have so many things
in it that it was easier I know thank
you
that's almost why you float better and
our Vegas for it's like all the bacteria
and the [ __ ] virus proven that pretty
much whatever happens in Vegas stays in
the Vegas pool water I've never heard
that that's why they collect there and
they got rid of it this is the only
place it stays and it wasn't just one
pool it was many pools throughout thee
and we love pools yeah so there were
alarming levels of GR urea what's the
yard yet Cryptosporidium oh [ __ ] it's a
crypto token cause diarrhea they are
parasites they give into your intestines
it was watery ass diarrhea Oh both
highly resistant to chlorine a number of
metabolites from human urine fecal
matter human mammal and avian which I'm
guessing is birds yes trace amounts of
cocaine ketamine and several different
opiates dan this pool is [ __ ] lit all
the pores if there wasn't trace amounts
of coke in the pool water [ __ ] Vegas
opiate placebo both of them well what do
you save money now let me feel better
anyways shooting you I'm confused as to
why they felt compelled to share this
because all of us here like oh he's just
like hey from a science percepts
perspective
don't open your mouth he was all plain
boring scientist he is aka your mom's
boyfriend the guy that you don't want to
hang out that much
the guy who ruins every debbie downer
ass yep he's like here's why you
shouldn't own a pet bird and
like oh god I already have a pet bird
okay [ __ ] you you know get all kinds of
bacterial diseases actually in like you
know there's droppings well most times
when you go to a hotel pool like at a
nice resort they have signs that are
like if you had diarrhea you're not
allowed to you know be in the pool why
is that because you can't tell if your
butt juices are like yeah things might
leak out a little bit
uncle matter so it's like you know they
want to avoid having that in their pool
people should the pool enough positive
if a kid shoots the pool you get
evacuated
I've seen it you've seen it so many
times we've got evacuated like three
times from a fool because yeah cuz of
all the poo a kid [ __ ] in it or said
[ __ ] in a multiple you get all the kids
off and then they gotta take the poo out
and we got to change the whole water to
it wasn't even a shame he was pissed
that he was getting taken out of the
pool to the side basically it's it's
nasty it's nasty swimming and you just
see like a brown log it's just just like
what the [ __ ] it's not fun when you use
water to leave swimming water with
fishes and [ __ ] and fecal matters and
are you swimming in so big bro that's
the thing it's so bad it's flowing to
like it's not just stagnant yeah the
moon and [ __ ]
hobby times even like Santa Monica you
seem like diapers in the water we don't
get inside never swimming don't swallow
that water no so people get Bali Bali
you know and viley middle anybody was
that it's a it's like the flu from like
it swallowing some of the salt water
there clean there if the moon creates
tides in our oceans how come it doesn't
do it in our pools mmm do the moves are
real
tell me about it what does it make waves
ah in all the bodies of water why
doesn't this have a wave that's moving
right probably cuz the earth is five
Habibi wow the moon is pretty powerful
yeah that's fine
is everyone no maybe not okay alright I
don't know if I'm ready to go to Vegas I
don't know I'm not even ready to go out
like to eat right now in LA
why because I feel like you know people
are so eager to get out right now that
they're kind of like just in a rush to
get there they're closer to us they need
to be anyone in Vegas I feel like this
is true that's not the craps table jump
along - you are a young man
yeah you're not a 79 year old
grandmother with cardiovascular issues
see better lives parents all died you
see my parents every week so I'm
concerned for them do you yeah I don't
need to see them every week but you
don't stupid little baby man Wow six
months wish yeah well let me know when
y'all go to Vegas I know not to come on
JK for a couple like a four month and
then we won't because we like to have we
already went that's no joke is I kiss
everybody on the mouth when I came in
that sauce was just the poor do that Oh
God okay are those press songs what are
those
I did him hey what relax uh you did him
yourself do not salt sprinkle a [ __ ]
this [ __ ] has been doing that too I
mean yeah but hers are like they're like
acrylic or something I don't know if
that means she got like the snake you be
theme laughter she doesn't support yeah
I had that too but my real nails yours
are better thanks I don't think I wasn't
gonna thing I just I know I want to come
with you I do like the color better on
hers because it's my spirit sports teams
color that's all I like that color is oh
I have a proposal how about this how
about we use Mary yes you already may
have a pitch I'll changing it no just
freak out like sports cleaned it up how
about we get in the car okay and you
pack for that week okay
we get on the car we drive to Vegas and
then we scope it out and if there's no
one there we enter the premises booked
some rooms have some fun if there's so
many people who come back well what's
the point they're gonna go gambling oh
don't you you're gonna have a lot of fun
I just want to see if it is empty if
it's just like let's say if J King goes
Buddha just JK we have to remind
everybody else okay but if there's a lot
of people there
we take a drop of hot sauce yeah and but
you stay there yes oh I don't know you
just punished yourself yeah so if we go
there and it's empty and they still have
[ __ ] $15 minimum craps tables I'm
gonna [ __ ] lose my [ __ ] I'll burn it
down
it's a lot like five bucks that's fun we
just go to the shitty oval toes but we
want to have the Aria experience with
light without paying are you you don't
want your dearly [ __ ] smoking and
blowing it in your face
this experience because no true ban you
know I get in the pool while you're
there okay all I'm saying is you're miss
hog what's the point of out of Vegas
what support there are gambling when we
spend money on a on a poker table that
we didn't use once they that's them
they'll be in this room
they used it be it to work I would do
weekly yes yeah we could go to a hotel
here well we don't have been willing to
have a poker night and nobody every Joe
keeps promising it to me for like years
now and I've never gotten to play poker
that's how it feels justice in the room
hello Joe makes a lot of promises and he
doesn't keep up what do you say to that
Jess
[Music]
[Music]